there was breaking news that was
delivered to me right before the podcast
i think we should at least touch on it
have we broken uh we have not broken
okay um something is very broken in
denmark denmark um here's a piece of
information i suspect you don't know oh
you remember joe biden
yeah yeah
joe he's got he tested positive again i
tested positive again he had what was he
oh
he was on pex love it wasn't he well but
here's the question was he
i think so but here's the question hey
i think that look i don't know i don't
trust anything that comes out of this
white house or the tests like even if
they were being totally straight with us
the tests are crap but right yeah i
don't know that they wouldn't oh my god
have reason to pretend but let's just
say that this is for real and maybe it
is just for real maybe they're for once
telling it to us straight he got coveted
he tested negative and he's now tested
positive again
um but that i mean that matches the
thing that happens with with pax love
but the other virals yeah but
these people are dumb enough to give the
president paxlovid
i mean that
that's news to me
right that's an i these people have
access to good information
they can get the drugs that work if they
want they don't have to take this
you know
frankinese [ __ ]
that they've assembled in the lab
because they can patent it frankenais
it's like a
frankenstein
uh enzymatic oh frankenace yeah
frankenace sorry
oh i see i see yeah okay no it's not a
good turn that's not gonna catch on but
um
it's not gonna catch on we can agree to
that but um but enzymatic chimeras right
yeah they can get him whatever they want
and these people
believe me they they lie like like
they're drinking water they could give
him ivermectin hydroxychloroquine they
could just
tell us you know that that they're
giving him you know all of the latest
fancy stuff from
from pfizer and merck and everybody be
happy but but i think when you take
either of those two
drugs that you just named i think you
actually sprout a maga hat on your head
isn't that right oh wow i don't know it
turns you into some kind of crazy
conspiracy theorist okay okay prepping
republicans suppose that's true science
denying wait no
it's one of those things but let's say
let's say that that's true okay so the
man's sick he's president they don't
want him to die because they don't have
anybody to run his place in 2024 among
other reasons okay so there's an op-ed i
think in wapo today um saying actually
what he needs to do is to say before the
midterms that he won't be running in
2024 because that's the only way that
the democrats have any chance of
maintaining any
any any kind of power and i think i
think the problem is as much as
he totally sucks everybody else in the
party does too so
presumably not everybody else well it's
real close but uh in any case a lot of
us are running away but there's no place
to run to right that's the running away
part is easy they're running too that's
a that's a much tougher call but okay so
suppose you're right and if you take
iromectin and hydroxychloroquine because
you've got covet that you sprout a maga
hat but can't they fix that in post
i would think so i mean they've got they
got people yeah they've got they've got
technical chops they totally do yeah i
mean remember that beautiful set uh in
which they pretended to be vaccinating
the president in a
beautiful austere room in the white
house no you never saw this picture no
oh there was a picture from an awkward
angle where the president is clearly
being injected with something in a
potemkin room and you know it just
really summed up the whole
the whole covet experience
yeah all right okay well that's it so
that's the breaking news yeah that's
that's the broken news
that's the brokenness that's the broken
noise
[Music]